【第二集】
朱老師 我們標股在現等
要做到第20集了
好誇張喔
可以做到20集耶
可是很多網友啊 還是很奇怪耶
會來講說 看圖說故事誰不會
股票市場不就是
高了你就賣掉嘛 低了就買回來
對 低買高賣
很簡單
但大部分人還是會賠錢
每個人都知道要低買高賣
問題是你怎麼知道哪裡是低
哪裡是高
所以你還是要有個依據
其實技術分析這個理論來講
它就是
以前的歷史它會重演
所以大家看的圖都是
以前發生過的圖
對
它現在又發生了
一模一樣
不管是形態
不管是趨勢
多頭空頭
它永遠都在循環
所以說你看得懂
你自然就比較
比較知道哪邊是低 哪邊是高
該走就要走了
重點就是哪邊是低 哪邊是高
對
那我們今天來討論一個就是
可以讓你知道哪邊是進場
哪邊是賣的點
我們每一集都是這樣啊
對啊
但是其實這個同學或觀眾
自己可以回頭檢討
你有沒有做到
問題是做到比較難
而且有些方法很簡單
很簡單
而且已經用了
可能有幾十年
幾十年幾百年
幾百年
如果以這個趨勢理論
那都已經一兩百年了
還是在用
所以我們今天來講一個很古老的法則
可是很有用
然後那個圖應該全世界人都看過
沒錯
好 我們來把它好好的分析
好
好 歡迎收看今天的
標古在線等答
最喜歡的朱家宏老師又來囉
我們已經做了20集了 20集樂業
20集交給大家非常多經典的技術分析
那今天我們的主題呢
我覺得應該可以得到諾貝爾經濟學獎
為什麼 大家知道諾貝爾經濟學獎
過去有很多理論其實簡單到不行
例如說股票市場沒有超額報酬
消息出來股票就漲了
這樣就可以得諾貝爾獎囉
好 但是今天講的這個叫做
格蘭幣八大法則
相信你有做技術分析的人
都有聽過格蘭幣八大法則吧
但是朱老師教的會讓你最簡單最易懂
那為什麼格蘭幣沒有得到
諾貝爾經濟學獎
我們可以來問一下朱老師
但是當你學會的話
保證你好不好
懂得什麼是高 什麼是低
我們現在講一下葛蘭壁好了
一天到晚聽到葛蘭壁 葛蘭壁
到底長怎樣
長得很帥
長得很帥嗎
你看這個不是長得很帥
還好啦 就是個老外
好像老外的電影明星
只是不知道他拍過哪個電影
難怪人家說鼻子有才
那是我們中國人的命相
我們來看一下葛蘭壁
它是一個美國的分機師
它也是
因為美國的
西方的股票市場好幾百年
但是它發明的時候
到現在各位看大概60幾年
我們是1960年
我們2021年
對不對
所以大概60幾年前
60幾年
不管是稻子理論
不管是個藍碧
我們都會發現
他們幾十年
剩餘上百年前發明的東西
現在還在用啊
全世界都在用啊
人性從來沒有改變過
沒錯啊
對 沒錯
都沒有變聰明
沒錯
因為這個人性
他就是在反映在市場上
那格蘭壁
它是經過了
前面一百多年的股市的發展
然後他就發明了一條
我們都知道均線就他發明的
均線是格蘭壁發明
有沒有講五日 十日 二十日
我們前面教學
教均線
均線就是格蘭壁發明的
葛兄
其實他就是一個
我們講什麼平均成本的概念
就是他抓一個成本價
大家在這一段時間買到
到底大家的成本是多少
如果大家的成本都在一條線上
那他可以用這條線
去觀察出很多的現象
或很多的進出的操作的一些策略
例如說你如果是平均成本100塊
現在股價110
那就是這個
高於過去的平均成本
大家都賺錢了嘛
大家都賺錢
所以它是發明一個規律
所以軍線也代表一個方向
所以軍線裡面
我們很注重幾樣東西
其實大家把軟體打開就知道
軍線很注重
第一個當然數字
你的平均成本是多少
第二個就很注重方向
你的軍線是向上還是向下
實際上格蘭壁八大法則
它除了講軍線也很注重方向
方向
對於我們
我今天給大家去講的這個實用
我是說我們學什麼東西都沒關係
那其實目的只有一個
就是用到股票會賺錢
理論歸理論
那剛才趙華講什麼
要得什麼LOB而講
讓你就去深入研究理論
因為得獎是理論
但實務並不一定去符合理論
我們先講清楚
因為股票市場本來就變化很多
理論是一個大數法則
那還有很多變化
可是他很偉大耶
你看量價理論也是他第一個提出來的
量價先行對不對
對
好 那其實格蘭壁的軍線
另外有一個很重要的就是我們講的乖離
乖離
那其實剛才大家同學已經知道
軍線是一個平均成本
那乖離就是你離這個平均成本太遠的話
就會產生反向 對不對
因為你跑的太遠了
那這個很簡單嘛
一個就是假如你的均價是100
你現在漲 一漲漲到120 130
那請問是不是我們剛剛講
就是大家都賺錢了嘛
可是你又賺太多了
所以很多人就想跑了
就想賣了
所以這時候你的股價就容易回來
那相反的如果跌得很深了
那大家又覺得很便宜
對不對 好像我們試價100塊的東西
哇現在只有60塊 80塊
那每個人都想買啊
對不對 因為你跟平均價錢
會有最內行的人先賣
然後大家再慢慢跑回來買
在感覺上也會啦
因為很多投資人看到股價低就去接
其實他也沒有什麼理論
他也不懂什麼記錄分析
但是因為他覺得便宜了他就去買
那實際上這個乖離了就好像
我們正常來說
猴子應該在樹上嘛 對不對
但是如果你一下掉到樹下面去了
那猴子還是有一天會跑到樹上嘛
或者有一天他跳得太高了
離宿太遠
他還是要回來
回到宿上
他要回到宿在你
所以這就是一個乖離理論
乖離是跟哪一個就跟軍線來比較
叫乖離
那格蘭壁根據剛才我們講的這幾個特性
所以他也在用他的軍線
有幾個買點跟幾個賣點
那這個就是我們講的格蘭壁八大法則
有八個點
對
其實我們把八大法則講完了
你就會發現我們現在幾十年幾百年
還是這個
我們的買點還是這個
這張圖可以用100年
對 以後還是用
200年
那我只有剛才講
現在可以
我們知道現在還在用
問題是你買股票有沒有用
重點是在這啊
理論大家都說這四個買點
這四個賣點
可是大家在拉到一個股票的時候
你有沒有按照這個理論去買
這才是重點
所以基礎分析就像趙華剛聊天的時候講
很多人不相信基礎分析
他說基礎分析都是歷史在講歷史
而且他覺得可以騙線
我有錢就做一條假線
對啊
也就是說大家都講
縣市人就做出來的
對不對
那個主力他在做這條線
那我也承認是主力做的
因為沒有人去買就沒有這個線
當然是有主力在後面買
然後就做了一個多頭的架構
那我講一般的投資人
就除非你是主力 你在做線
那我們一般投資人
那怎麼樣在市場
能夠知道哪邊是低 哪邊是高
我們剛剛開場講的
就是看這個線
主力怎麼做這個線
主力做這個線是要賣了
他要跌 還是他要主力要攻了
我們才可以在技術分析上看到
所以我一直講說
一般的投資人就是小資主好了
我們就講小資主
除非你要去得落標的講
那你就去研究很深的理論
也沒有啊 我剛剛講的那個也沒有很深啊
可是你想要說股市我輕鬆簡單
不要太複雜 賺錢
那你只要懂 會做就好了
格蘭幣軍線有八大法則
就等於八個點 四個是賣點
四個是賣點
那我在這邊大概先介紹一下
他第一個賣點就是
當股價跑到軍線上了
但是還有一個條件 軍線要向上
軍線向上
那他的理論在軍線上有講嘛
因為軍線向上有支撐
所以你只要骨架到我軍線上
即使疊 我下面有個支撐
你就比較不太容易馬上就被破壞掉
所以他如果你的骨架
站到軍線上
那他又是加量理論的發明的人嘛
所以他說如果你站上我的軍線
軍線又向上 再加上有量
你就很容易成功
這個股價就容易漲
其實蠻簡單的
站在軍線上
軍線向上又有量
又有量
就容易成功
所以在這個位置你就可以買
也許這個時候
股價還不見得轉成多頭
他只是強力反彈
也可能是反彈
但是你上去了
你就有一段獲利的機會
是
第二個位置當然
就是一直在軍線上
那你回來到軍線
那軍線理論講這是資深
就是朱老師也常講
上漲以後回後再買上
對 回到支撐點
然後他撐住了
就是股價又放量又漲
這是第二個買點
這兩個買點不太一樣
第一個買點是從軍線下跑到軍線上
第二個買點是回到軍線
他沒有下來
回到軍線的支撐再買
是
第三個買點就是
我們剛剛講漲太多了
很多人在賣
賣家中了把軍線跌破怎麼辦
那跌破當然就不能買了嘛
因為這個在軍線下也不能買嘛
那你就不能買了
那什麼時候還有一個機會
就是在戰上
我們這個叫軍線的助長的力量
他幫助他漲
因為軍線裡面
軍線他在研究的時候
還有一套理論叫慣性作用
軍線在向上之後他有慣性
除非你把軍線彎頭了
這個慣性就沒有了
只要他維持向上
他有一個慣性
有一個慣性
關鍵就是
他還可以幫你拉一把
因為你跌下去了嘛
是不是你賠錢了
但是我軍線大部分的人
這個軍線的方向還在向上走啊
所以我還可以幫你拉上來
所以當你拉上來的時候
你又可以買
這個叫跌破軍線
再站上軍線
你就可以買
那同樣的軍線要維持向上哦
如果向下就不行了
向上是一個很重要的標
向下就沒有支撐力量
那這裡有三個買點
其實這三個買點在我們現在的
教學的技術分析裡面是一樣的
都要站到軍線軍線向上
這樣還是多頭排列嗎
對 回後買上漲
因為你沒有跌破軍線
當然一定是多頭
因為軍線向上
所以你碰到軍線一定比前面的高
對不對
那跌破了你在站上
還是維持軍線上
所以你也可以買
那他還有一個很特殊的買點
他很特殊賠點是強反彈
我們平常的術語就是強反彈
那強反彈就是這邊疊很深
那剛才講一疊深就很多人來買
所以他要強反彈
那但是他強反彈在格蘭壁來說
他就有條件
因為空頭每次都會反彈
但你不能每次都去搶
所以我們講空頭是不要去搶那個反彈
那為什麼格蘭壁說可以搶
因為這裡有個條件就是
剛才我們講的他跟軍線的乖離過大了
你已經跌得很深了
所以這個時候他就容易談到軍線
那這個時候因為你跌深嘛
所以你跟軍線離得比較遠
那你才有獲利空間啊
否則軍線這是壓壓
好所以這邊是一個強返談
強返談
但是這邊都是一個多頭趨勢的買點
多頭趨勢的買點
所以強返談我們等下也會告訴你
在什麼狀況下你才可以講
好不好
因為有花大法則
我們今天先講買點的部分
4個買點主要是幫我們理解
大家都在做多比較多
所以先把買點做多的先學會
好不好
我們第一個買點剛剛講了
股價在均線下又跑到均線上
然後你有放量然後均線向上
這三個條件
如果你有看到股票有這三個條件
你就可以先去買
但是如果不是多頭
你就是先買一個短線
是不好
那我們這個有了
讓我們來看實力
好 實力
你就會發現很多股票
為什麼在這個地方你都不敢做
對不對
當然不敢
老師你有教我
他漲三天我不要追
這叫空頭反彈
空頭反彈有的時候會彈一段
所以我們就先去做這一段
那這個位置符合格蘭幣的第一個位置
格蘭幣第一個位置說
骨架從下面穿到均線上
而均線向上
這個地方均線是向下的
這個地方均線向上
可是朱老師這邊已經大漲三天了
對 所以叫
所以叫格蘭比的第一個法則
那你不買個我也可以啊
我就第一段不賺就是了
那你買了呢
那剛才講那漲四天會不會跌啊
那你就把庭審收好就好
好不好 你要坐第一個位置嘛
朱老師你講這個很重要
因為我很多觀眾朋友聽完去買了第一根
可是可能已經漲一段了
買了第一根被套牢
但是要守紀律
對 要守紀律
在我的教學裡面
這個位置是不買的
因為你前面是空頭
所以我沒有買
但是如果你要去做
格蘭壁八大法則就可以
那我們來剛剛看
這個老師不是也站上去嗎
對
那為什麼不能買 也有量
因為軍線還沒有上揚
對
所以我們剛剛講做是一回事
理論告訴你了
可是大部分做大家就亂買
其實你失敗了你去看
你少了一個條件
你的均線是向下的
換句話講你沒有做到
你就賣嘛
也沒有問題
你也沒有什麼太大的損失
所以這是我們進場的第一個位置
股價佔到均
那這你的均線我講一下
我們用20均
為什麼
因為20均月線
因為20均的月線
他的支撐力量才強
如果你說我站上5均
那個很容易跌過
平均成本太短
所以我們都用20均去看
如果你看到有20均站上
其實我上課也講過
股價跑到20均上
基本上已經轉強了
你已經可以把20均的壓力突破
20均又上彎
所以他有支撐力量
再加上你有量
所以這三個條件有
這個叫先做一個試單
它並不是多頭
可是你還是一樣
如果有賺到兩天三天
你就賣就好了
因為它還不是多頭
你就等一下是多頭再來做
這是我們的第一個買點
第一個位置
好 我們看一下第二個位置
第二個位置剛剛就比較簡單了
因為它已經上來了
它已經上來了
它已經多頭趨勢了
軍線也在向上走了
那其實你再回來不要破軍線
紅K再漲就可以買
那這也是大家最容易看懂的
比較容易看懂
好 那我們來看看這支股票
各位也很
有這個最近太陽能權
前面是不是有經過空頭整理
有的
月線是不是下彎
那剛才有講
這個月線跑上來
但這個月線還在向下
所以你不要在這買
這個不要買
當然你也沒賠錢
可是你大概也賺不到
現在反過來
月線向上了
我又回到月線了
這個時候又起掌又有量 就很符合了
對
格蘭比的第二個位置
回到軍線 然後放量
然後上漲 就表示軍線有支撐
所以這是一個很好的位置
那我在這裡強調一下
我一直跟同學講或投資人講
我們要實作
我們真的是為了要進場的賺錢
對
對不對
所以我一直告訴大家說
我知道了
如果你再回來
月線如果有成果就要做了
所以你在平常這支股票
還沒有漲的時候
這支股票你就要去注意它
它現在就要回來
然後你回來你看月線說在向上
對啊 那是不是要等這個位置
等於說就是要把它設定到自己
說股民大名啊
對 我既然學過技術分析
我知道月線如果不跌破
上漲的時候就是一個買的位置
而且是可能必須發明的
不是我發明的
我只尊重葛蘭壁的法則作
所以你如果在平常就知道
它已經上月線 月線向上了
那你是不是等這根紅K就可以買了
所以重點就是說你學完了
你能不能夠在股市中
你把它用到
而且事先就去等它
所以你到時候這根買的時候
你也沒有什麼猶豫
因為這就葛蘭壁進場的位置
你就買就好了
那有沒有百分之百成功
沒有
所以你把停損收好就好
停損一定要收好
我都一直重複講這個方法
因為為什麼呢
這個就是一個操作紀律
你碰到停損你就賣
沒有碰到停損你就賺
你是賺錢嘛
這個就是用技術分析操作
那我們再看一個明顯的例子
是不是同樣的
站上越線越線向下
你暫時就不要動
其實他還是有漲
他還是有漲 但他又回來了
那我們就回來的時候就是你要等了
所以你一定會等到這一根
等到他站回月線上 月線又上彎
而且這是現在的股票
現在月線是不是還在向上
所以我就會講說
不是這個你沒有買到
你就覺得你看我都沒有了
不會啊 不管他了
你後面我們有四個買點
你再來啊 你在這邊
再看到這個月線
你看這天是不是在這邊震盪
如果月線又因為這叫乖離過大
對 乖離過大
如果我月線乖離變小了
那它又發動了
所以又可以買了 對不對
所以舉一反三
講一個你就自己再去舉一反三
所以這支股票現在
還是可以鎖馬的
還是可以鎖股的
只是要等它回到月線上面
回到月線或者月線沒有跌破
它就攻了
那就最好 月線還在向上
對
符合嘛
所以你就可以做
好
再來講一檔
因為朱老師說第二個這個點
其實最容易看懂的
那我們就看長一點
好不好
那你就知道在這個過程中
其實你有好幾次可以買
對不對
只要它有 沒有就不買
跌破月線我就不買了
這樣對不對
你看這個地方是不是月線向下
現在月線向上
你是不是有一個
這邊月線向下這個不會買
這個不會買
月線向上 你買囉
那現在漲上來
你說沒有賠錢吧
你賺錢嘛
那月線靠到了
剛才講這邊盤整
是不是等月線靠
月線靠到了 公喔
是不是紅K 有沒有大量
是不是你敢買
那月線說還在下面
買 你說賺到
好 回後買上漲
他有回喔
回到月線 又看到紅的了
又有大量 買 你說又賺到
朱老師是不是有些股票
特別容易回測月線壓力
因為我後來有發現有一些全之股
很容易這樣子
因為月線是一個比較長的均勻
漲多了都容易回到月線
就是你跟月線怪力
大概都回到月線
所以你發現
你如果在這個地方
就看到月線上揚
你做一次
做兩次
做三次
做四次
你有五次可以買
買了以後
當然你看你怎麼做
你要做短線
我們就講跌破五均賣
你要做長線
跌破月線賣
對不對 那如果你是在這買
或在這買 你在這買
月線在這你才賣
如果你是做長線
如果守月線的話
對 那如果你沒有買
你這你可以買
這你可以買
你好幾次可以買
那每一次都是
格蘭幣的第二個法則
對不對 都是回到
我好像也會
也因為有另外一檔權之谷
也有這樣的特性
回到月線會上去
沒錯 沒錯
所以格蘭幣這個
這個法則的月線
是我們很重要
是
那像這個是不是跌破月線嗎
對
那你有沒有買
沒有
有沒有
不行買了
他也沒賺賬
而且又下彎了
而且就不會了嗎
對
對 你就不符合橄欖壁的進場
你就不要做
好 那再來講
第三個
那跌破了怎麼辦
我們剛剛有嘛
對
那橄欖壁說你不要急
還可以買
但是要站上來
橄欖壁好鼓勵我們
對 不是
他要說你等他站上來
好 跌破了
但是要再站回去
站上還有啊
月線還要向上
月線還是向上的
向下你站上你也不能買了
對不對
所以你要月線
剛才條件還是不能變啊
對
站上月線月線向上
下面放量
來要放量
就可以買
好
你又可以買了
又可以買了
那我們看有這樣例子嗎
有
跌破了又站回來
很多路口票
一跌破月線大家都以為完蛋了
但馬上又站回去了
但是當然
我們先看好不好
這是跌破了又站上了
對
可是月線要維持向上
這你要放量
好 跌破了又站上了
月線向上這你有放量
所以還是會漲啊
對
還是會漲啊 對不對
所以最重要就是你趨勢不要破
你不要變成空頭
你只要還是維持多頭架構
站上月線 月線向上就是你的買點
所以你還是可以買
所以有的時候短暫
但這裡要提醒大家
對
所以我們大家有聽句話嗎
跌破月線最好三天以內趕快站上去
他要把它收回來對不對
也就是跌了兩三天趕快站上去
那為什麼 因為你太久不站上去
月線就會彎
就會往下彎 因為扣底上來了
就會彎
這樣子OK嗎
所以只要兩三天之內站上去
月線沒有彎
當然你可以做
只要趨勢不要變
所以大家要注意囉
如果跌破了
跌破太久了
就月線開始打平
下彎了就不符合格蘭幣的法則了
就不符合了
你看我們這支股票
剛開始漲是不是在月線上
那月線從我標這個意思說
月線從這裡你是向上了
你已經可以注意
可以注意它了
月線上要合
我注意了半天
結果跌破了
跌破了
不敢買了嗎
沒有
如果我是格蘭幣
第三個買點我就等
等
等到第二個位置
你就等到
後面不得了都是你的
因為這時候月線還在向上
又有放量
這裡是要放量 它又符合
所以有些股票
近期它回來你就去注意
注意這條月線有沒有過
最近剛好買多股票回來了
趨勢沒有變
那你就掌握這個進場位置
在我們來說就是回後買上漲
不要跌破月線
很多人在問朱老師
什麼回後買上漲
其實就簡單就告訴你
不要跌破月線
有的時候它沒有到月線
但是回後你就可以買
那就更好
就測試一下
就不要全部砸下去
你就可以買一部分
你就可以買
好
剛剛講第四個買點比較特別
第四個就比較複雜囉
比較複雜
第四個它因為要
要乖一離
那乖一離要比較大
你才可以買
那第四個買點就是
在復乖離過大去強反彈
那我這邊就
拉一個圖例跟大家講
怎麼樣規律
什麼叫做覆覆離過大咧
我們用股票講就比較清楚了
因為你股票會打開來看
我中間這條是20
那什麼叫覆覆離
當然就跌破20很遠了
這個叫覆的
如果在上面就正了
那我們一般的統計來講
統計如果覆覆離到15%以上
那你這個覆離就
覆覆離就叫過大了
如果這時候有放量
他就很容易貪
就是要靠月線去
他要回到月線
我們在這支股票
我們在電腦的軟體上
也可以設的
這不需要自己去算
你就去設什麼
我中間是20均
是 月線
對 我上面是證實5%
證實5%的乖離
也就是如果我跑到這上面來
他就會回來了
對不對
這就有點像布林通道的概念了
布林通道是不太一樣
他是用標準差
兩個標準差
那這就純粹
所以我們自己設定15%
我們在電腦設定15%
這三條線是平行的
因為他跟他15
跟他15
所以這三條是一樣的
那布林通道不是
布林通道有時候很窄
有時候會打開
會破散
好 那我們就很簡單
我們看現在二十均向下
那股價跌跌
現在沒有很大的歸離
結果突然跌到15%
乖離變大了
那你有紅K去上漲
他就會去靠越線
那你看這一段
如果好像太小
你就不要去搶了
那看這一段
跌
他已經跌破15%囉
對
那是不是乖離已經很大了
那這時候如果紅K上來
他是不是會靠越線
他就會去靠
所以你還可以搶到大概10%到20%
你可以搶到這個範圍
主老師15%是你個人的經驗值嗎
對 大概啦
你看這邊到15%
那超過15%就更好
是 超過15%
你這個反彈的幅度就更大
超過15%是不是不行
你下去才會超過15%
你沒有上來你不能買
所以一樣要回到
設定的這個歸理的這條線上面
可蘭壁八大法則是不是跌下去
要上來一個紅K嗎
你要買那個
我們講的回後買上漲
你要買上漲 不是買下跌
你這你還在下跌
你不能買 就不能買
一定要紅K上漲
他上漲過了昨天的高點
他就轉槍
那這時候他往哪彈呢
先彈到月線
那彈到月線你就看到黑K
就代表這個月線一樣
這是買紀訊號4
他是強反彈
對 強反彈
那我們就用這個15%的乖一離去觀察
那另外也給你做空回補的參考
對不對
我做空報的好高興一支低子
就反彈了
現在乖一離已經到15了
超過15囉
改為補一下了
你要是有反彈就補一下
所以這個用法你不去買強反彈
就是你空單要回補
因為你怪力過大
所以訊號是有兩種功能
它就很容易
好 但是剛剛有講到
朱老師用的是月線
那很多人說一定要用月線嗎
到底我軍線設什麼比較好
因為我們剛才在介紹
格蘭比的法則
所以用一條軍線
你看得就比較清楚
就這一條嘛
你去看這條向上
那我們平常在上課
教大家是四條均線
四條均線
五十二十跟季線
六十五
對不對
主老師你今天六十五
我看有人是六十
有時候是六十
其實六十六十五
我跟同學都講
你也不要計較
你回去
你把所有的均線都關掉
你開一條六十
開一條六十五
你就只開這兩條
那你上面是不是只有兩條均線
一條是60
然後你看這兩條均線有什麼區別
其實是靠在一起的
既然靠這麼近
也用一條就好了
所以60、65都可以
所以不要因為每個老師的習慣
有的習慣用60他就用60
那正確的用季線來算是65
那就用65
實際上你兩條擺上來是一樣的
只是一樣的
這樣子大家就沒有什麼說
一定
差五天好像很了不起
那五軍跟六軍有什麼區別
對不對
以前都用六軍
因為一個禮拜交易六天
現在五天
五天
那你把五軍六軍兩條線都打開
其實是貼在一起
是 差不多多少
所以你用五用六都沒有什麼不對
那這樣我解釋你就可以了
那我們在平常你用四條
是
那四條各位
我為什麼要去用這四條
其實我們在前面
軍線的排列都講過的
如果同學把前面
我忘了第幾集了
均線多排按照順序
三線多排六線多排
重點就是要三線多排
對不對
50 20要多排
那我們剛才講的是什麼 20
所以你一定要在20上面
對不對
在20上20會幫你撐的
所以我們看這麼長一個走勢
這個松藤也是最近比較強的股票
一直都在走
其實他走了那麼久
各位有沒有發現
20至上跌破20
然後打底之後要再轉多嘛
又在20字上
跌破20
這是我們剛剛講的喔
跌破的越線又上越線
對不對 是不是
跌破了嘛 是不是又上來了
越線還在向上喔
那你又可以做
因為你這個回憶檔
沒有破前面的第一點
所以你還是多頭
多頭又上越線
你是不是在這個第八個位置又做了
這是我們格蘭壁法則的第三個位置
大家回想一下
等一下重看一下前面講的
那你在這做 它說又漲了
好 跌破20 然後又上20
這個沒有跌破20
一直到我們上課都還沒有跌破20
如果你去看20
所以20是一條很強的
是一條很強的支撐線
那你做武軍當然你進出就比較多
基本上走到現在
各位看季線有沒有用到
沒有
沒有用到
你根本就用不到啊
所以我們平常只要把三條均線守好
就好了 記線你只要在下面
因為你在上面記線會有壓嘛
那所以我在打底的時候
如果四條均線多牌
這支舞票你就跟著二十去做
你就這樣跟著做
你就可以做很好了
那在二十呢
我們就去觀察個藍B的那幾個進場位置
你都可以抓到
聽起來很簡單
做起來可能大家還是要注意
有三個一定要注意嘛
這個一定要注意嘛
一個是趨勢要向上
軍線要上揚
而且他要站回軍線
然後要放量
你這幾個配合你自然
我們的意思是說
其實也才只有30個
沒有講到十幾個讓你記不住
你就34個條件
那你就把這個節目看100遍
100遍謝謝朱老師
我真的
你看100遍你也會背了
你也會看
我也會教
而且因為我們有股票的圖利
不是只有畫那個圖嗎
我有股票給你看
下針你的股票你就套上去
是不是符合這樣
符合這樣你就做
然後把停手手
好 所以格蘭碧八大法則的買點運用很簡單
但是呢
因為我們剛剛有講
很多東西你加一點點調味料
滋味會不一樣
所以我們在我們的榮耀班
大家注意了會有進階的交法
格蘭碧八大法則的四個買點
再加上一個小秘訣
會讓你的勝率大幅提升
請記得加入我們的榮耀班來收看囉
好 今天非常謝謝朱老師
我相信喔 很多人每次看我們標股在線
都會說 哇 過去我搞不懂K線
過去我搞不懂軍線 過去我搞不懂東西
朱老師全部一次讓你高動
今天格蘭碧八大法則
趙華聽完就覺得
原來我在日常生活中
用技術線型過已經默默在用
但是你會注意到
你可能有時候是
觸到月線你就買
有時候你沒有注意到
有沒有放量你就買
雖然很簡單
只有三個法則
可是你可能會記不牢喔
所以朱老師說這一集看一百遍
你的格蘭比八大法則的四個買景
絕對不會忘記不會錯過
希望今天的標股在線等
對你的投資有幫助
那我們下次再見了
Bye Bye